welcome back to Google developers weekly
for february 3rd 2014
I'm Louis gray and so highlight reel of
what's happening in the world of Google
developers on the set and off since the
introduction of Version three of the
YouTube data API many developers are
migrating from well version to as you
might expect from new york jeff posnick
walks us through the api calls you need
to get a list of the videos uploaded in
a given channel featuring live demos
using the API Explorer you can learn
this in more at youtube.com slash dev in
our second event highlighting Orbitz
integration with Google Wallet Yousef at
all of Orbitz joins Martin Bowser to
demonstrate how their customers earn and
track loyalty points called or box using
the Orbitz and Google Wallet
apps Alex Meyer community manager for
Google cloud platform took the stage
here in Mountain View to announce live
the winners of the Google cloud
developer challenge there were 12
winners from six regions of the world
did you win or you want to find out who
did check it out and if anybody asks I
voted for you tomorrow's great apps are
going to come from mine's much younger
than my own and the best way to get the
kids coding is to teach them how early
developer advocate Julia Ferriero Lee
spoke at Ashleigh Gavin about her work
with girls who code and how she develops
curricula that appeals to everyone and
our GDL weekly wrap ups would not be
complete without another appearance from
our Udacity CS 256 mobile web dev team
Chris Wilson Sean Bennett and Peter
lubbers are back with a 3rd edition of
office hours tackling lesson 6 and 7 you
can cram on our YouTube channel and find
out more udacity.com slash course / CS
256 in addition to all this great stuff
the Android developers team brought us a
new dev bytes focused on recording out
videos and our personal favorite best
practices for playing games as far as I
see any game I win was designed
perfectly check them out at
developers.google.com slash live slash
Android also dart fans got a new release
of the dart editor in the dev channel
this week lots of cool new features
including the start for support for
angular and JSON quick assists check it
all out at dartlang.org and to make sure
you never miss a thing from the world of
google developers subscribe to google
developers on youtube and check out the
gdl schedule at
developers.google.com/live I'm Louis
gray and I'll see you in the studio